joining me now Fox News contributor and
former South Carolina congressman trey
Gowdy congressman that's huge if they
can get this through Congress and you
can allow American citizens to file
litigation against the Communist Chinese
that's a game-changer what do you think
the chances are that that happens in
this political environment they'd be
really good and you know Tommy and Dan
are to be commended we need a change in
the law because of the Sovereign
Immunities Act which makes it almost
impossible to sue other countries in US
District Court you've suggested you're
going to have the challenges of getting
the information from China the discovery
as we call it in the legal realm and
then and then the damages I mean if
you've lost your life or lost your
business or suffered injury you're
entitled to damages but you got to
collect so that individual route is one
way to go there's also a need a
responsibility for the world the whole
China accountable I mean if you cannot
warn other countries that a pandemic has
been unleashed you have no business
being a leader on the world stage so
there's the individual there's the world
and then there's what our country can do
and I think where we can hit them the
hardest there is to is to oxer sized
them but also to reclaim our
manufacturing reclaim our pharmaceutical
manufacturing in particular there there
are lots of ways we can hold China
accountable I totally agree with that
because if the Shuar on the other foot
this was an American company it was
doing dangerous research it spread
throughout the world causing massive
economic pain and even death and the
Trump administration had tried to cover
that up I mean they would have brought
Trump in front of the Haig and brought
him up on war crimes charges that's how
significant what happened in China was
now the w-h-o you know just so people
know this guy dr. Ted Rose who was hand
picked out of Ethiopia from the Chinese
this guy actually gave a goodwill
ambassador ship to the tyrant Robert
Mugabe of Zimbabwe I mean that's just
the thought process
behind the guy that's running the WHL
now we've cut funding we're launching an
investigation what do you think this
investigation is going to find and even
if it finds that they were complicit
what do we do about it
well you know they have a four billion
dollar budget and we contribute a lot of
that money so you know we we can and
should cut off the money I think there
ought to be an entity that kind of
coordinates pandemics but but let's look
at the WHL and their track record from
the inception of this virus they first
told us that it could not be transmitted
human to human then they told us we
didn't need face masks Jesse I'm a daddy
in my last science class you don't need
to give me four billion dollars to tell
you exactly the wrong information I'll
do it I'll do it for free and then and
then all the heels
I'm telling us it couldn't be
transmitted then they gave us this
stellar piece of advice if you're gonna
sneeze don't sneeze on someone or sneeze
into your elbow and that's what we got
for four billion dollars two things that
are wrong and one thing that our moms
told us wow that's an expensive piece of
advice all right trey Gowdy thank you
very much